i like throwing out a curveball at the
beginning if for both of you if someone
has actually never seen anything that
you've done before what is the first
thing you want them watching and why
oh wow yeah i'd probably say princess
diaries too just to see how how
how much hair i can have
never had the best of luck with hair and
films but what do you mean it just means
that i have i have some i have hair i
mean
my hair in that [ __ ] film
i need to go and watch that check it out
okay it's or something oh wow
um and i got to work with gary marshall
and anne hathaway and all a bunch of
stuff but it's mostly for the hair
emergency for the hat yeah right on
the end
um what would i want them to watch
oh norbert of course
things that's the only one everyone has
seen so let's just stick with it
i'll be honest of all the answers i
expected out of both of you neither of
those were the ones and i say awesome
you're welcome
we aim to please
and you did 100
um listen i know you guys both read a
lot of scripts uh what was it about this
script that said oh i definitely want to
do this
it was just simply that one of the
better scripts i've ever read it's one
of the best grips i've ever read front
to front to back no question i've read
it repeatedly which i you know is hard
to do sometimes with the stuff you read
i was constantly surprised
it has an incredible romance at the
center and the heart of it it's got a
great yarn a great puzzle
it's an espionage spy thriller so it's
got the cobblestones and the european
streets and the in the street lamps and
the great lighting and all of it it's
basically
straight down the center pierce the
heart of my cinema lover's uh body so um
this is the kind of form i want to go
see on a friday night it's the kind of
foam i want to sit down and you know
make a bunch of popcorn and listen to
the rain hit the roof while i
while i watch it it's just my kind of
film so i loved every part of it
do you wanna you wanna um why why this
film
i mean obvious chris has just laid it
out but me personally i
i i it was just out of the blue an
absolutely fantastic opportunity truly
in every way
you know we were in a pandemic in
lockdown and yet we were going to try
and complete this ambitious
project the script was fantastic and
then obviously
you can have all of that and maybe not
gel with the people you're working with
but i really enjoyed janus's
um ideas about the movie and really
loved bjorn mcenroe and the work he's
done loved armadillo his documentary
absolutely [ __ ] amazing man
and then chris wants to do this movie
and is producing it it was just bang
bang bang all the pieces sometimes you
get that they fall into place i mean
chris has been doing it for for years
but for me it was just like this gift
wrapped there silver platter go get get
your heels on have a nice time really
it's wonderful
so the entire movie uh pretty much rests
on that restaurant scene it's the
beginning middle and end you know it's
everything and i'm curious as actors
when you know that this is such an
important part of the movie are you can
you sort of talk a little bit about how
you like to prepare
when you for like big scenes that you
might be filming i like talking about
actors in like their process is there a
certain thing like a certain way you
like to get ready that is maybe changed
along the way or do you have a similar
routine
i would say that when i first started
out i was very um
result oriented um and i watched
performers who do this as well who i'm
i'm intrigued by although it's not the
process which i follow but
you know in order to protect the
performance you keep kind of keep the
performance between boundaries that are
quite tight and what i see in those
performers is that they know what they
want to do they probably don't trust the
director editor to deal with it so they
kind of want to give a performance about
that big so they can basically guarantee
that their performance will look a
certain way
i very much used to approach things that
way and as i've gotten
older and and
more invested in the experience and the
journey of it i have a lot of time
divesting myself of the responsibility
of figuring out what the [ __ ] it's going
to look like and really just playing on
the day i might have an idea of what's
what i want to do and i've
thought a lot about it and how you know
my own self resonates with it but
mostly i just want to go
party i want to go like what are you
doing what are you bringing to the table
you know right let's play let's figure
it out and it could completely change
you know you need to have that
spontaneity don't you really
um but some people i don't think you
know i think that is very actor
dependent it's very very very actor
dependent and project dependent too yeah
you know i think for the the scene that
you were talking about the restaurant
scene one of the things that was quite
complex about it which is one of the
reasons why i'm so glad i've worked in
theater actually is because we
approached it really like a sort of
piece of theater because we're talking
pages and pages and pages and it wasn't
just it wasn't all on camera a lot of it
would go into into flashbacks but in
order to give janus
the full freedom in case he did want to
play some of it in
not in flashback we basically shot the
whole thing
as a conversation even though in the
script a lot of it was in flashback do
you understand like they'd be our
voiceover but you'd be seeing scenes but
we had to do the whole thing just in
case so it was pretty
i i approached it like a piece of
theater where it's not just about
learning one scene it's learning ten
pages of work and you don't usually do
that in film do you you just do the one
scene you're gonna do that day or the
three scenes depending on the budget of
the movie but this was way more and i'm
glad that i had that
experience in theater before
approaching that that's those scenes
honestly
uh my last question um chris i have to
ask you i'm i'm a big fan of your
directors on dungeons and dragons and
that is the reason why i am actually
really looking forward to the movie uh
the filmmakers and obviously your
performance but what can you snuck into
that but i mean but being honest like
the director
is obviously very important to
delivering what you're going to see um
what can you tease people about the
movie because it's been sort of quiet
and i'm really looking forward to it
oh man well what i will say is we had a
hell of a fun time making it there was a
lot of laughs um
[Music]
the way that i've been describing it
it's like
game of thrones
mixed with a little princess bride
just a smidge of um
uh holy grail
um
oh
gosh
yeah it's somewhere in that ballpark
it's a lot of fun it's got a lot of
thrills it's poppy
it's 80s heartfelt there's like a bit of
goonies in there
um
uh
my character is uh
is uh
he's uh
he's the ultimate party planner
i think it's gonna be really good i mean
who [ __ ] knows but i think we got a
good shot and john and john are are our
killer guys they know they know comedy
and they know heart and we had a great
cast and we had a good time making it
and um that's all you can ask for
that's the reason i'm so excited listen
both of you congrats on the movie and i
wish you nothing but the best thank you
for giving me your time thanks travis